okay hi everyone welcome to a
design meeting this is our
language completeness and consistency
meeting
about
features of the wolfram language
and how to make them more complete and
consistent
you know i just realized that
completeness and consistency is just
like what people say for
for logical theories like it's the thing
goodell's theorem shows can't possibly
work for
the um
certain class of logical theories i
hadn't really realized we'd named this
meeting series after the same idea
okay
all right
default values format values and values
sub values
scary business
um
right so
um
mostly
uh
uh wanted to uh
um
you know look at some of the notes and
there there is this one issue with n
values um
but uh
i think i needed to get um
i need to get things updated right
now i don't think we've really touched
the pages and since last week so yeah
this machine i updated them today
and also this machine that i'm using
here i'm not in my normal habitat this
is not my normal file system ac
but i would strongly suspect the thing
is is um
oh gosh it's going to be really slow
well i can try opening this anyway it
may mess up
uh
okay what's the page i should open
uh well let's start with format values
i mean these are very ancient things
these are 35 years old basically right
and um oh yeah that's not the current
version
okay it's probably from
10 years ago i don't know i this is not
promising because this is a slow network
connection
perhaps i can share instead
uh
sure hold on one second let me set
something up here
um
no that's not the right thing
um
ah it's because i have that connected to
that
okay
um hold on one second
[Music]
okay
go ahead and shop
[Music]
okay so
um
right so format values has this internal
page but we've never i don't know why
you know it can be documented own values
down values and some and
up values but not i don't think we
thought about these i mean i think we
should think pretty carefully about
these we have an opportunity
um
to do something modernizing for these
because we've never documented them
um
so for our values of f
is
what happens during the format phase of
the i mean it's like the format
evaluator so to speak
right
and n values is similarly like the n
evaluator
yep
so a question that i have is what's the
general case of that concept
so in other words what we're saying is
we have these kinds of values that are
not
part of the generic i mean to me this
relates also
to the concept
well okay so we have an ordinary
evaluator and these things weave their
way into the ordinary i don't quite
understand no they don't they they they
they they're never part of the evaluator
right they're never part of evaluation
right formatting happens after
evaluation when you i understand when
you've reached a fixed point
right you reach a fixed point so there's
no evaluation to be done by the main
evaluator
right right
and so
you know
um right so this is
right it gives printing valid printing
formats involve rules for format make
boxes and make expressions
so in fact format values can be called
either before or after the main
evaluator depending on
whether these are
right but does it assume
in the resolution of a make boxes
specification does it assume that the
evaluator will be called or not
someone's saying does it assume as an
interwoven thing that the evaluator will
be called
i i don't that that question makes no
sense to me okay look
one possibility is you've got an
expression which is inert
okay
and then this is giving a further
transformation on an inert expression
it's not necessarily inert right in fact
this is part of what makes writing
make boxes rules difficult right that
you need to be careful not to allow it
to further evaluate as you pick it apart
to
format it
so does that answer steven's question
that it's possible for at least a poorly
written format value
to change the underlying expression and
therefore the evaluator is in fact
involved
yes
uh
yes i guess basically
all right let's zoom out a bit i really
don't think we should just steam ahead
and document something we've left
undocumented for 35 years
what's that well i mean we made the
decision to document it
yeah you know after repeated user
requests i mean you were part of this
meeting i know but but i'm i'm recanting
somewhat because i think that the issue
is
you know
in
okay my question is although
let me let me point out something format
values has nothing to do
or has next to nothing to do with how
formatting happens just as
down values has next to nothing to do
with how evaluation happens
right
down values is a representation of the
rules you've created it's not actually
the rules i mean you can sort of use it
to manipulate the rules but it's not
actually the rules
right
well but the question is i mean what we
should be doing is reviewing what we're
doing for these secondary evaluation
types of values
because
again there's a general concept of
i mean
look really okay
why are these not up values of some kind
or are they in a sense generalized up
values in a sense they are specific of
values
uh they
i mean well you can attach the rules
either to make boxes directly or to your
head
right
so in that sense so my question is could
there be a general mechanism
let's say i want to introduce you know
nq as well as n
right
could i have something where i can just
say i mean i i can right now i can just
say nq of f blank blah blah blah equals
blah
and i mean that's really no different
you know format make boxes
the format values if i say make boxes of
f of x blank colon equals blah
that will associate that rule with the
with the format values of f correct
um
[Music]
well probably with the format values of
of make boxes but
really
uh
i thought format values i mean i thought
the whole point of format values was
like up values that it got associated
with the you know the head in question
rather than just the generic function
so
um
right so if i say
make boxes of
f of x
blink
you know
standard form
gets bob
then
format values of f
is empty and format values of make boxes
i don't understand this at all
what even is that
the heck is all of that
what is all of that stuff
well those are
rules that
you know i guess
the cloud object people rather than
attaching the rule to
the cloud object they
attached it to make boxes for some
reason
which
i would claim is a bug on their end yeah
i think that's a horrifying thing
right so why is this okay how do i get
something associated with the format
values of f
well you use tag set
okay and why would i know to do that as
opposed to just doing the make boxes
rule
well that
may or may not be documented that we can
document it
i mean there are times when it's
convenient to associate it to something
other than the head of the first
argument
for example you might want to attach it
to traditional form
but
um
the uh
okay look
what i think about this is i think this
deserves a deeper review
i mean the question of whether we
i think this whole thing about secondary
evaluators
requires a deeper review because i think
we either want to introduce a mechanism
in modern times
where you know we understand so many
things better than we did 35 years ago
where you can
have a
general way of introducing blah blah
blah values
you know we could have imagine a
function
called extended values
right where extended values takes the
first argument that's the type of value
it is and the second argument of the
head that's that we're you know
exploring
making sense
well
i mean you expressed a logical thought i
don't necessarily agree with that
thought
um
i mean i think i think
documenting these things that exist is
useful to users
um and uh well so what are the issues in
documenting what's there i'm not a big
fan because i think it's a bit messy
by the way to answer your question about
the tag set i see it in the applications
for make boxes
and it doesn't otherwise say anything
about that
well it's it's titled define the
formatting for a function
so right it doesn't call out the use of
tag set
but it's
explicitly saying here's how you define
the formatting for a function
right
okay
okay all right so what are the questions
here so what were your questions about
format values
right so
um
well i guess there's uh
i mean there is one
oddity um well i mean one is sort of
generically
are you you know i'm setting i'm
creating a usage box that matches what
we did for
own values of values down values
and
so you know getting your sign off on
that
there is this one oddity that
which i i think has to do with the fact
that we went you know
with version three going from the output
form world to standard form world
that
rules of the form format the one rules
for the one argument form are used when
formatting an output form
that's so 1980s
and rules for the two argument form are
used for the other
forms um
yeah well i mean it would help
probably on that page to have a table of
the other forms
because not self-evident to me could i
do it for c form or something
probably not
yeah you can define first you can do it
for any of the okay why don't we get a
list of which forms one could do it for
okay this is a very long in the tooth
subsystem in my opinion
doesn't mean it doesn't work but i just
think
it could be made more general and
sleeker
but i don't also don't think it's the
highest priority thing to worry about
right now i think that the you know the
idea of mix-and-match formatting rules
which we have discussed for for millions
of years
the idea that for example you could say
i want traditional form except that i
want my
uh
i don't know my powers indicated with a
wedge or something
right
this idea of mix-and-match rules we've
never managed to figure out how to do
see what i'm saying
sure
um
it's uh
i mean
well i i don't think we've invested much
effort in it recently but it's i mean
it's a ridiculously hard problem because
you know
assumptions are made everywhere not just
in our code but in user code
well what do you mean i mean the issue
is
look
the question is
given something like traditional form is
there a named way to bank switch
different kinds of features there
it's similar to the probe of error
messages is there a named way to bank
switch which messages you want to get
um
see what i'm saying
well yeah but i i don't right i mean
there are
you know
as a practical matter
right there you know
there are assumptions that people
make where
oh if i just do this it'll look like
that
and so they use it so okay you you
change how power works and suddenly
you know 17 other things change or maybe
don't change because you know he decided
to form for format it and
force it in some place
yeah i understand and they do an input
form and it's got a bunch of crud in it
that they didn't think was there and
blah blah blah
right to me
this project it comes up
every so often and i notice it when i
want to you know format something in a
particular way and i want to say why
can't we just have a general way of just
saying
you know in you know having a big long
list i mean what it amounts to
and this is something we should consider
as a project just like we have a great
big gallery of graphics possibilities
based on different option settings and
just like we have plot themes
why don't we have format themes
see what i'm saying
so you switch your formatting from
physicist to electrical engineer or
something for example yes
yeah i think people would find that very
useful i mean we just didn't have the
idea of plot themes we didn't have the
idea of themes
when we were designing the standard form
traditional form etc structure
right i mean well
okay we should move off this topic
because i have a
as far as i'm concerned
i'm not thrilled about documenting this
because i think it's you know we have
held it undocumented for for you know 35
years basically
specifically because
34 years maybe for this one i don't know
well even really it's 25 years because
the format values of version 3 is quite
different from the format values of
versions one and two
no so we changed it
yes
well we had to uh right make boxes and
make expression didn't exist in versions
one and two
um
right i think i think this right so um
right so when would you assign
to to
right so this is this is the weird thing
that that i agree i mean i'm not sure
what what what would break if we were to
change this but
um
right in any way but this is one of the
weird things i noticed right so
i guess when you when you assign it
the one argument form it creates rules
for output form standard form and
traditional form but right so it creates
space well it basically creates two
rules one for output form
and one for standard form and
traditional form and when you but the
actual right the thing that it creates
for output form is a one argument thing
and the thing it creates for standard
form and traditional code is a two
argument thing my opinion is that the
right thing to do here is to
you know zoom out a bit and ask the
question in 2021 how would we design
this
right how would we design
kind of the thing that allows users to
add formatting information
i don't know the answer to that question
i think we should answer that question
before we commit ourselves to this
and you know once we know the answer to
that question we build a bridge back to
whatever we have right now
but let's answer that question because
for example i think you know format
themes is a good idea
which would solve a bunch of problems
and how that relates back to this i
don't know so that's what that's what i
would like to suggest that we you know
commission an effort
to just think about
for format values and n values what are
the other ones default values that's
another can of worms
well i don't think default values is
that bad i mean uh
i mean
and and certainly i think i mean i think
sub values don't don't really doesn't
have any of these issues
um right now how deep does sub values go
it goes all the way down it's the header
goes all the way down
i mean i think it yeah
well i mean we can by the way the blue
and default values probably should be
default values
yes it said for what values though
uh
yeah
that probably
um
right name yeah so it it goes
as far down and so here well here we
have a two arg
do do we have a three three
three guy maybe we don't have an example
uh but i mean yeah i get it it's always
the head of the head of the head
right
so
you know
and i don't know what happens with with
um
uh
tag set if it's the head of the tail of
the head so to speak
well again
look we just haven't looked at this
stuff
in decades okay
so it's a mistake to just say let's burn
in everything we're doing having not
thought about it for decades
you know we should just have a think in
modern times okay what does heaven think
mean
it means somebody's got to dig in and
think about it
and i'm not sure it's
i don't think this is the highest
priority but it means
it means
you know ask the question
if necessary in one of these meetings
ask the question
starting with what we know today how
would we design these features
because we haven't documented them and
we didn't document them for a reason
which is we were not fully happy with
that design
we thought it was kind of arbitrary
that's why we didn't document them for
all this time
so i mean again i just said several
things we should look at for format
values like format themes
well sure
i i agree the other question is
evaluation of a format you know when you
evaluate a format value what exactly
role of the evaluator is taking place in
other words is there any sandboxing of
the evaluator or does it just do
standard evaluation it just does
standard evaluation is that the right
thing
well what's the alternative to that i
don't know a sandboxed evaluator i mean
we have the concept of controlled
evaluate
which we have not implemented yet
but i could see that that will be
relevant to this
like for example i can imagine a format
value
where you're trying to format code how
would you format code using format
values
some bizarre thing with hold form where
you know as soon as you touch any of the
in code inside the whole form as soon as
you take it out of its of its you know
protective bubble the thing will explode
well i mean that
well
i mean
well i'm not sure if you're asking about
you know the formatting rule or the
um i'm talking about the right hand side
of the formatting rule and i'm saying
that
what we have here that there's a
question
of okay let's imagine you have a piece
of code
right
and
wouldn't it be nice if you could just
say just like you can say command shift
t to put something into traditional form
that happens without evaluation
that's not
completely true it goes through it goes
through more or less the same evaluation
of make expression and then make boxes
okay so technically it's technically
slightly different it's going through
convert form but it's basically
consulting the format values and doing
this but if i say two plus two and i say
command shift you know if i say let's
say i say two wedge two let me try it
try it yeah yeah i mean sure but try it
try it i'm just want to make sure i
understand what's going on if you say
we're not seeing wherever you're typing
oh there we go okay type two wedge two
to wedge
tube which no no no no not that which
just start regular
shift six
okay now go select the cell
and now say convert to traditional form
right i do that which is exactly the
same thing i would get from
make expression
of
rope or i guess yeah i understand of row
boxes but it isn't the same thing okay
so the question is no no no no no no no
no no no no
it still went to the kernel via the uh
link from the front end right
so
uh
what
superscript box
right so
right so
okay but this is you so so this happened
uh oh i misspelled
super
so this happened and then
make boxes
at percent happened
i get it i get it i understand but to
the user it looks like you started off
with an expression
that was unevaluated to wedge two
and without evaluation
you did
transformation to traditional form which
is all good
but what i'm asking is programmatically
if
if i had like a piece of code that was
in a hold for example
say hold of two wedge two
yep and now i try to write the code that
will do the thing you just did
well that's make box that's make box
that's raw boxes of make boxes
at that right
okay but let's say we want to do the two
wedge two transformation
you want to do
i want x
two not two plus two yeah i want to do x
blank wedge
y blank and i want to show it as a
superscript
um
oh
i don't get what's happening there
right this is an expression right it's
the this is the expression power of two
comma two
make boxes takes that expression and
converts it to boxes and then we display
those boxes
okay what happens to the raw boxes
well then you'd see the superscript box
right yes
yeah but now what happens if i instead
of saying hold of two words two i say
hold of superscript box or superscript
two comma two
well you get something that looks pretty
much the same thing
but it isn't it isn't the same in fact
it's not
and that that that's because right we we
we don't want that
right superscript is designed to produce
boxes that won't get turned into power i
understand that i understand that
look
i don't think this is properly thought
out for for what we know today i mean
again it's going to be an hour-long
meeting just in its own right to talk
about this i think it's a fine thing to
talk about but let's
you know whether we have to break these
into separate discussions for sub values
versus format i think we should have a
discussion about format values
yeah i think we should start with that
because i think that's the most
interesting and the most complicated of
these
okay
okay and let's let's get that on on an
agenda we can even have its own custom
meeting if we if we think we can swing
that
okay okay because this isn't it's it's
you know let's not give up the
opportunity that we've created for
ourselves by not documenting these
things for decades
and let's think about
you know
you know i don't know who else should be
involved in that discussion of what can
we do today there's several other people
who are interested in that question
i mean i know you know jason harris has
worked on this for years
and there are multiple people who will
have opinions about this and we should
try to get a meeting specifically about
this topic
okay
all right let's go on to the next you
can punch
go ahead
right well i mean
we shouldn't document any of these we
don't know what we're doing
let's let's let's we've
we made a mistake previously by saying
let's just rush and document them i
don't think it's a good idea
and i don't think anything is going to
burn if we don't document them this this
week so to speak
but i think it's
well
other than you know the hours ian and i
spent writing all of these pages well
they may very well be things where we
just press the button to say
finish them
okay well and
well i i will point out that i think
i really don't see what the controversy
over sub values is but i don't either
that one seems the least dangerous
so right because that this one right
this one doesn't this one really doesn't
have any weird stuff it goes straight
into the main evaluator i'll check the
thing about multiple levels and
maybe i'll report back on sub values
right i think sub values we could do i
think that sub values is the easiest
default values is next in line i think
both format values and n values are
difficult
yes and and n values in particular has
an issue with infinity that
okay well let's also ask the question i
mean then rob knapp should be involved
in the n values thing let's get the
right group of people for each both
format values and n values i think these
are both opportunities format value is a
particularly good one
okay
all right once you unshare then i can go
back and share again
all right
oh boy
oh wait we have some horrifying stuff
here
well okay i guess i missed this
when i was looking at the agenda the
agenda should have included the thread
on
[Music]
right there was an email thread about
this right so we talked about this last
time and you said we should figure out
what people do out in the world and i
did
some scans and
said well this is basically what people
do out in the world and michael trott
agreed what's the answer
so can i say that yeah right so
basically they do
a
you know basically they do a column with
conditions
so in the case of
so we should see that um
send it by mail and i'll pick it up here
[Music]
okay that's
why am i not a horizon
okay did you send it i just now located
it so it's being in the process of being
sent
i'm beginning to regret saying sure
let's do this meeting today
okay did you send it yep
or at least i think
my email client is
uh
spinning maybe if i
i haven't received it
okay let's go on to the next thing i
mean unless you think there's a very
definitive answer here do you think
there's a different advantage well i
think i mean we have something that's
implemented in a branch
okay and and show it
well it's what what you see on the
screen
but you just told me that people
formatted in a column of some kind
right and the the the that's what there
is there
you're you're not sharing at the moment
i know that and i'm not getting the mail
that you sent so
okay well i think we have to put this
through another time
there
but
so what are you saying that this delta k
equals two is that a real thing or not
yes
so what do people normally do do they
normally write that or do they write
something different
they well it depends on what the
condition is
i mean so the most common thing
is to actually just re-index so you
don't have anything but
when
you know when you do when you don't do
that then
you know they'll write that you know
write the condition they'll have a
column with a condition or conditions
you know
what do you mean by a condition you mean
k less than 17 or something well you
mean k not equal to 17. or k odd you
know
okay fine
divides three they write might write k
equals one to nine and then underneath
they write k not equal to seven
right that's the type of thing you mean
by a condition right
sure
okay we don't have a
do we have any way of representing that
construct
some from one to nine excluding 17 a
seven or whatever it is
not as such no
okay so we therefore don't think we care
about having a format for that correct
correct
i mean
okay
because for us what we would do is we
would write if k equals
seven
zero otherwise f of k
right
sure or we would uh
yeah that would that would be a
what does this look like if this is a
list
if i if i do it that it doesn't format
okay so that will be a thing to ask
about
so that will be a k is an element of
that would be
what what we might say there is you know
um
okay so if i want this and i say
traditional form of that
comes back with nothing so i mean what
about this why doesn't this look like
some
and then underneath k element of three
four five
or k equals three well
five because
you know unlike the the
the other case it
um
you know this could
just you know
so the case that i had that is
implemented actually has a reasonable
chance of looking respectable in
uh
in a formatted form whereas the
arbitrary list case does not
well unless it's just two values k
equals minus minus one sure but what
what what are what what are the odds
that you're going to call sum with the
list of of two things i haven't the clue
i'm going to clue
well i think
well
in this case you would just write the
sum you would do this plus
yes i agree
i agree so this case so what i'm asking
you is what do people do in this case
where you know if they say i would
imagine they say k equals one comma
three comma dot dot dot
am i wrong
uh
i think
uh
you obviously have examples so let's
look at the example in in that case
stephen i think he would have somewhere
you know
like say capital s
your mail still has not arrived
you would have like you know somewhere
capital s equals your list of things
maybe with the dot dot dot
and then you would sum over you know
stuff in s
i understand that yeah but that's not
this case i'm asking about this
particular case here
where there's a where which is the case
that you say was implemented in the
1990s right is the case where there is a
step
how do people write the step in the
literature and you say the number one
thing they do is to transform it so the
step is one i get that if they're going
to have it with the step not being one
what do they write they they will write
you know k
k equals one to nine k odd okay so they
will write the words k odd underneath
right so they'll write a constraint
underneath
right
okay
so they will not write
a delta k
kind of thing correct
um
i guess not i'd like well um
unless we can usually we need to look at
that
what you actually found
but let's look at what you found when we
can see what you found but i'm not
buying this given that nobody seems to
do it in the literature
and although it's somewhat clear what it
means
i don't know and if that's a finite
difference delta that's a very weird
object because that's a finite
difference operating on a variable which
would normally i don't even understand
what that would mean a finance
difference operator operating on a
variable what would that mean
uh
i'm not sure okay let's move on let's
move on we're going to run out of time
in nine minutes so let's move on
okay
okay file
this is about grep
right
so
ethan is pointing out that
uh
file system map and file system scan
should have some more sophisticated
options and i think i agree with that
we implemented them
as
initial in-core
kinds of things so let's have a little
talk about file system map for example
actually file we have file system map is
a
but both are an interesting both are
interesting cases
so one question is in what order do you
visit the files
right
which right now
is undefined right they're visited in
the order that they appear in file names
correct
uh while it depends uh
uh
okay so so that brings us back to the
question of file names what order does
file names return files in
i believe the answer to that is it
returns them in alphabetical order
correct
so
the the idea would be to have a sorting
option for file names that would also
serve as a sorting option
for file system scan
am i making sense
just like when you you know in any old
file browser you have a
you know a sorting option
right you understand what i'm talking
about yes
so you're talking about sorting by
date statements size
whatever you can sort by in standard
file browser
i don't know what can you sort by date
modified size kind
how about that first beginning
right
is this the wrong set of people to
discuss this
what uh well i the question is what it
what it what is the this that you want
to discuss
talking about grep and and we're talking
about we're talking about turning
file system scan
that's a good idea from ethan
to have a traversal order right what i'm
saying is that's the same problem as the
question of what order does file names
return the files in
i i don't understand
why you would care about the traversal
order and in fact in order to transfer
you know guarantee a traversal order
you'd have for example
twice
no you wouldn't the operating system
gives you the list of files
uh-huh in whatever order it decides to
give them well let's talk about that
implementation question
um
right so one thing you can do presumably
okay so so let's let's understand this
right
so one possibility would be
but i i will also wait a second wait a
second wait a second wait a second the
issue is the file system map
automatically picks up the list of files
right
okay whereas it could be the case that
file system map
takes a list of files
and maps over that list of files but
that's equivalent to map then
great
okay
but the point
being made is
okay one point
is
what happens
to
okay one question is this is
automagically
doing the files in alphabetical order
that's not obviously correct
clearly you can do a key sort at the end
but the question is if for example you
want to terminate early like as soon as
you found that let's say you do file
system scan
and
as soon as you found something so i mean
this is where sorry i i already want to
quibble about alphabetical order
because
i assume that it's um doing parents
directories before navigating into
subdirectories though i could be wrong
about that
which might not be the same as
alphabetical order when you include the
slash or backslash or whatever the i'm
sure you're right that separator is
right so it's a depth first order of the
of the tree it's a depth first traversal
of the tree
probably
first where what i mean by depth first
is it alphabetizes at each level
similarly lexicographic order then does
the sub trees then recurses back up
right well right but now if we make
right if we make any sort of guarantees
about traversal order then any sort of
parallelization or optimization we can
make that way is lost well let's talk
about that for a second okay
okay
so
i agree that a progress monitor would be
nice
that shouldn't be too hard to add
i mean
right now presumably the first thing
file system scan does is to find the
list of files correct
who does somebody who implemented it is
somebody who implemented it here
no well then let's do this meeting once
some that person is here okay
okay but but in terms of parallelism
that's an interesting idea
again we have the wrong set of people
here to discuss that
but in a case where we have a fire
shared file system
and this is a read-only operation which
this is
correct is it correct that this is only
a read-only operation
yeah what is a read-only that would
depend on app right if i if i did delete
file if i did file system map of delete
file then it's obviously not okay
okay fine so it isn't necessarily
but file system scan
no it again is not
it's not read only
okay the question is if you have a
parallel operation
and you have
right the question is could we run this
in parallel
you know in other words how equivalent
is it to parallel map of
f applied to these files
do you see what i'm saying
let's see if we can have one topic where
we actually have the right people here
okay
well i you know
ethan's comments were about grep i don't
see
where his how you're jumping from his
comments to file system
what what is
okay what's the difference between grep
and
i mean it's like a file system cases or
select
well right so right so grep looks
i mean obviously there are different
modes but grep
you know finds
occurrences of a string in a file or
files
that's defined it does
no it's not
find finds the first
find takes a stream
and it moves the stream past the first
line that contains the given text
grep returns all occurrences
in a
is not this find list
ah i forgot about find list
right um
yeah and you can limit it to the first
end right so i guess scrap is files so
grab by guess is
file system map of find list why does it
need the file system now
um
well because at least as oh in the file
i see the
this is i see
right the first argument is a list of
files i guess we could add a recursive
goes to whatever
[Music]
right and i presume i presume it would
just barf if you give give it a
directory name at the moment i'm sure it
does fine list work with a pattern
like a string pattern
that's what i was wondering because i
was wondering how you get context
yeah that's the other thing grep gives
you right now i mean this is an
unbelievably old function okay
this was a was this version one no
version two wow it's modern
right i i you know i'm i'm just saying
right which is why i was saying you know
the the existing functions don't fit
very neatly into i mean find lists
certainly fit
you know the email
that was sent to tlcc mentioned find and
file system map and i i was saying
that's not a good map
or okay so fine so we've also got the
issue of
okay we've got several issues here we've
got
okay if we were going to design a
greplike function it seems to me a good
place to start would be to try and have
a function basically called grep that
can be put in the function repository
that has the features that we think it
needs
okay which probably means returning an
association
that says file name line number blah
blah blah
snippet blah blah blah
i'm i'm a little bit unclear wait a
minute what's the difference between
that and text search
why isn't what we're asking for just
text search
uh it doesn't text search look for you
know not string patterns but
the
you know um
right i thought it looked for
well how about we find out how about we
do this iterate this again with the
right people here okay
but i agree that it's a reasonable thing
to want
both
sleeker
file system map
the one thing that's absolutely clear is
the progress monitor is clearly a good
idea
and uncontroversial i think
isn't it
okay if nobody says anything we can't do
a meeting
that
is that uncontroversial
uh have a progress monitor
well i mean it's not something
right i mean we can't give really a very
good progress monitor
right we could have one that's saying
you know
scanning
i write it's scanning j of j max but j
max would be continuously increasing as
it recursed over the
the the directory structure
you could just show the current file
name couldn't it
well
if it doesn't necessarily know how many
files it's going to be scanning
up front well it may know how many
spells it may be
we don't know because the person who
implemented isn't here so we don't know
if it knows how many files there are to
scan
it doesn't
look if it's one directory it knows it
just does stat on that directory then it
knows if there are nested directories
then it doesn't know
right but well yes but so there's a case
in which it knows
and that case is not an unimportant case
well
right but the default is to recurse
right so i understand that so it would
have you know i don't know what stat
exactly returns does it tell you if
there are any directories in your in
that directory
i don't think it does but yeah we don't
know but we don't know
yes i'm not certain okay right i i'm
just saying it what it won't write until
it knows
right so if it happened if it were so
lucky that the first directory scan had
no subdirectories than it would know up
front but other than that
right it's not going to know i
understand so we try and do the best we
can which includes just saying scanning
this file but i suspect we can know and
it's not obvious to me that it
we should we don't know what the code
does so let's not waste our time
discussing this because the code may
for whatever reason i don't know what it
would be
up front figure out what files it's
going to be scanning
it may need to do that for reasons that
neither you nor i know
or it may not need to do that i do not
know
huh
no timed is obviously wrong
look the problem is it looks really
stupid to say dateless plot for a thing
which lasts two minutes
am i making sense
it thinks so
um
you just don't like the formatting of
the times as you know 237 to 239 or
whatever no i don't care about that i
care about the name date list plot if
the span of time involved is two minutes
saying dateless plot is kind of stupid
see what i'm saying
independent of what defaults there are
for the actual
uh you know formatting of the ticks and
so on but it's taking dates right it's
not right that the x-axis are still
dictating
data objects or time objects
right brett
yes
okay but i mean it doesn't treat time
objects any differently than i don't
care yes it's it's we're talking about
time objects and you're you know you got
to know the kind of secret knowledge
that even though your data is specified
as a time series with which could give
have time objects in it secret knowledge
actually use dateless plot to plot that
that seems silly
you get what i'm saying
i get what you're saying um
i don't think we need timeless plot
but i don't want to get into why right
now
because
we all need to leave soon
and it will come up soon enough
okay well hopefully it'll come up in
part of the design of time series
right like you can just say list lot of
a time series right yep
that might work
that might work
i agree that might work
that would be a good solution probably
why didn't we do that originally
why didn't we build more things into
list plot originally
i mean this plot of time series does i
mean it works right now just does stupid
things with the ticks
um
because it's just showing absolute time
on the x-axis
but that's just a bad idea
is it showing up to the time maybe it
just throws away the time stamps it just
shows indexed i don't remember um
okay but but so long as that can be
fixed then we might have a solution here
which i consider to be a better solution
than adding another
and then what i suggested
yep
so
okay
this wasn't our best ever lcc
it felt like
you know we didn't have the right people
and we weren't really at the right we
hadn't didn't really have the right prep
for this
um
but
uh
you know
that's what this process involves
this is some
polishing
and uh
there are rough edges
um
but uh
okay anyway look i i mean
just to summarize i think this one look
at sub values look at default values
then we need other meetings about format
and n
this one
i
i don't know i just think this is
probably one of those lost in the code
type things
by the way i think i still don't have
your mail at all so
uh
okay so i'll i so something went wrong
there yes
um
so if you can send that out then at
least we can take a look
um
i sent it to you i don't know if you got
it
i did not
oh wait a minute here we go i did get it
i apologize i did get it
i did get it i'm sorry
oh it's part of a long thread
right so
yeah uh oh
[Music]
right so i sent an email michael
responded publicly in support and linked
to some
examples all right i see these examples
i mean these examples as you say they
give a condition
like p even or something like that p
equals n mod m that's what i'm seeing
here
right
right i don't think we're going to
synthesize something that says you know
k is congruent to blah mod whatever
because we can't even do that
i mean to me what this is saying is
there is a way that people do sums
specify sums that we might consider for
some itself which is a condition
and then we would have a way to format
it
but can you find even a single example
where somebody has a notation
for the pure
i mean i've done this myself and what i
write is k equals one comma three comma
five comma dot dot dot and then i write
an infinity at the top
or whatever it is
right that's what i've done
so i don't think we like that
particularly
okay
all right let's wrap up here
okay
thanks a lot guys see you later